la colère ne retombe pas à portland la
ville du nord ouest des états unis est
devenue l'épicentre des manifestations
contre le racisme qui dure depuis la
mort de georges floyd à minneapolis le
25 mai dernier le déploiement des forces
fédérales par donald trump depuis le
début du mois de juillet a eu pour effet
de durcir le mouvement
surtout après la diffusion de vidéos
montrant des manifestants brutalisés par
des agents fédéraux
des heurts ont de nouveau eu lieu cette
semaine à proximité du tribunal fédéral
et d'autres bâtiments gouvernementaux
les forces de l'ordre russes fréquemment
de gaz lacrymogènes et de balles en
caoutchouc pour contenir les
protestataires
des pratiques dénoncées par les
manifestants il n'aurait pas dû faire du
mal aux manifestants beaucoup de gens
ont été gravement blessés je pense que
c'est vraiment une injustice sociale
les gens aiment jeter des choses mais je
ne pense pas que jeter une bouteille
d'eau équivaut à tirer sur un tas
d'autres personnes
je ne sais pas si vous voyez les
blessures ou pas mais j'ai moi même une
ecchymose à la jambe en ce moment c'est
à peu près aussi gros que de m'être fait
tirer dessus et je ne leur avaient rien
lancé j'étais juste là les policiers ne
se soucie pas vraiment sur qui il tire
ou de ce qu'ils font ce n'est vraiment
pas quelque chose qui devrait se passer
cette présence de troupes fédérales est
aussi critiqué par de nombreux élus
démocrates
plusieurs maires de grandes villes
américaines reproche au département de
la justice d'avoir servi les intérêts de
donald trump en envoyant des agents
fédéraux en réponse aux émeutes ont
entendu ce mardi devant la commission
judiciaire de la chambre des
représentants à washington le ministre
de la justice williams bar a dû se
justifier à cancale nous craignons que
ce problème ne produisent des métastases
dans le pays et donc nous pensons que
dans un lieu comme portland
nous n'avons pas le soutien de l'état
des autorités locales
nous devons une position et défendre ce
bâtiment fédéral va atteindre un stade
nous acceptions ce type d'attaqués
violentes sur les prix but no cd rom les
autorités de l'orégon et le gouvernement
de donald trump se sont entendus ce
mercredi sur en retrait progressif des
agents de la sécurité intérieure les
troupes fédérales ont évacué le centre
de portland laissant le maintien de
l'ordre à la police de la ville mais
pour le président américain
pas question d'évacuer complètement la
sécurité du territoire ne quittera pas
portland temps que la police locale
n'aura pas terminé le nettoyage de la
ville des anarchistes des agresseurs à
trois mois du scrutin présidentiel la
question sécuritaire s'invite dans la
course à la maison blanche donald trump
tente de faire du maintien de l'ordre
dans les grandes villes démocrate
un argument de campagne pour sa
réélection